you guys are gonna love this
what's up fellow geeks zacky here back
for another video and razer has sent us
three exciting products for us to try
out now for those of you who have
followed closely on our social media we
have launched a new twitch channel this
is where we play games build legos and
just have a good time so do check out
all our social media links in the
description below we are there do
consider subscribing and liking this
video it really goes a long way and help
us to keep doing what we love with that
said let's take a look at razer's newest
line of live stream products and
accessories that might potentially level
up your live stream sessions
what we have is the razer audio mixer
the razer serum bt and what i have in
the background is the razer key light
chroma so let's start with the lights as
we all know when it comes to video
production and even live streaming that
having ample lighting and good ample
lighting is a very important factor and
this is where razer came in and give you
the whole package
it comes with a telescopic arm it comes
with a ball joint hit so you can
actually swivel it from 90 degrees to
one to
another 90 degrees from from vertical to
horizontal when it comes to our own live
streams we'll just take our led panels
that we use in our own videos
slap it on there plug and play adjust
the levels and you're good to go it's
not that hard but the caveat here is
that it takes so much space you've got
like two light stains leds that kind of
just burn your face
sometimes it gets really hot as well so
what razer has done is to provide a
solution where you have a small form
factor
it doesn't take too much real estate on
your desk space especially if you're in
the home studio on a little room and you
still have the lights are pretty bright
okay 400 i gotta admit and i gotta tell
you guys everything that came with the
key light chroma is so well built
everything's sturdy it's made of metal
the clam holds and with such a premium
design it comes with a hefty price tag
it's quite expensive i would say okay
this is not one of the more
competitively priced ones okay it's 439
singapore dollars for the us folks it's
300 bucks 299.99
it's a lot of cheese it's a lot of money
it doesn't necessarily have to be used
strictly for live streaming hey in fact
i'm using it right now for this video i
can change the brightness sweet it goes
to cold at 7000 kelvin all the way to
warm at 3000 kelvin very nice very moody
you know very romantic and even has an
rgb effect so yeah
it's quite fun oh
red wow
rgb spectrum baby let's do it it's time
to party
yeah have a good time more importantly
how does this perform in an actual live
stream setup so let's change out from a
mirrorless camera to the razer keyo pro
a standard webcam so what i have here is
kind of a simulation of what a live
stream would look like with dim lighting
or really bad lighting now i got the
razer keyo right here the razon seren v2
pro
and we're all hooked up into live stream
on my laptop on the side over here now
as you can already tell the lighting is
not really that great we got harsh
shadows beneath my neck right here i
look really flat and you can also
probably tell that there's a little bit
of noisiness so what i'm gonna do right
now is i've got the razor streaming app
and i've already paired it via bluetooth
onto my phone and i can just bring up
the brightness a little bit you can see
there's so much difference
right now
and i'm going to also change it to make
it look warmer
bring some life
into my face
this is what it looks like now the white
balance is also set to auto adjust so
it's trying to keep
white white if you will but you can
totally see the difference on uh the
main camera on the a7 3 right now one
cool thing about the razer key like
chroma is that you can daisy chain up to
10 of these lights so you must have a
lot of money if i was a rich man
i don't have a second key light chroma
but one way to simulate what two-point
lighting would look like i've got an led
panel right here and we're gonna switch
that on
so you can already see that there is a
significant difference once we add one
more light now you gotta adjust your
white balance settings on the webcam
itself for the main camera you can
totally see that it looks pretty good
already
so with a second light you can really
play around with it adjust its values
and you kind of get a pseudo cinematic
look
at least on the main camera but you know
wet cam hey
handsome
moreover because this
has rgb
you can really
tune it up you know add some life into
your razer key light chroma and since
i've already got one white light there i
must make this rgb and can give me some
accented lighting look at that
so when i face the camera boom
it's a little party i'm still well lit
but i get to play around with rgb take a
look at that oh
hello
hey look it's party time
take a look at that yeah
oh
that's really rgb now
now if you're a streamer that struggles
with the very complex and cumbersome
process of adjusting your audio levels
on the fly in obs or maybe you are a
music streamer that wants more finesse
and control over your audio levels then
the razer audio mixer might be the
solution now the razer audio mixer comes
in at a whopping 387 singapore dollars
thereabouts or us 249.99
which honestly speaking is competitively
priced if you think about other products
particularly the go xlr mini it shares
the same retail price however the xlr
mic input is also a hybrid 6.3 mm input
so you can plug in your guitars on your
music instruments or even a karaoke mic
if you wanna and moreover you do get
chroma rgb on the razer audio mixer
because hashtag gamer
alright so let's take a quick look at
the controls of the razer audio mixer at
the top here we have the four channel
interface each channel dedicated to
music game line in xlr
optical in
and we also have dedicated mute buttons
over here we also do have a censorship
button send censorship so during your
intense gaming sessions if you ever need
to censor yourself you can just do this
so by itself it's already a very
powerful tool for your live streams now
to take it up a notch let's dive in into
the razer synapse app right here on the
front page at the customized channel
this is where we can actually tune and
tweak our audio channels right now i got
all my audio sources where i need it to
be but just to give you a drop down menu
here chat music game optical aligning
the system
and you can also change what you want to
do with the long press button so whether
it's presets whether it's muting a
specific channel
or even toggling a different vocal
effect you can do it all right here
now going to the mixer this is where it
gets really intuitive
so based on output mixer alone you have
seven dedicated channels we have four on
the audio mixer console itself
seven in the software and you are able
to customize which of the four channels
on your console you wanna dedicate these
audio channels to
now what we have below that is the
playback mix and this is what you are
monitoring with the headphones you can
see that i'm having my headphones on and
i can actually listen to myself on the
fly if i wanted to have a music running
or my game chat running i can also
toggle any of these switches to include
those mixers into my headphones we also
have voice chat and also control the
line out now line out would be
a speaker setup that's where your lineup
will go to and your voice chat will be
the levels that you have on discord
now the most important thing right here
is the stream mix this is important
because for those of you who are live
streaming this is what your viewers will
be hearing and you can also route the
different channels to your stream mix
now for instance if i'm live streaming
and i want a little bit of music i can
include that in if i'm having a discord
chat
i would activate chat and of course if i
have a separate microphone i can include
that as well so yeah really really
loving what razer has done with this
razer audio mixer it's super intuitive
there's lots to play around
with it and
you know i know it's gonna help out with
all those advanced uh streamers out
there who really need this and really
want more fitness with their audio
controls
now with that being said there's still
lots to cover with the razer audio mixer
and we'll probably do that in another
video so if you want a more detailed
video on the razer audio mixer and
perhaps a tutorial with different setups
and configurations do let us know down
in the comments and while you're down
there maybe you want to consider
subscribing and liking this video moving
on this is the razer seven bt bt because
it's bluetooth now i gotta admit that
i'm surprised at how this performs okay
it's also very very portable because
it's so small there's no other
transmitters or receivers this is it it
pairs via bluetooth to your mobile
device now for what it's worth this is
priced at 160 singapore dollars or us
99.99 so very very affordable
competitively priced amongst the other
products that's very similar to the
syrian bt now this is catered to folks
who are irl streamers or vloggers who
mainly do their content with their
smartphone but of course i've tried it
in various setups and configurations
including pairing this bluetooth to my
laptop and it still performs the same
way it does with a smartphone so let's
dive into the specs and the key features
now this has six hours of battery life
that's pretty long okay for streaming
content
you've got usb c charging with a quick
charge from zero to 100
in just 1.5 hours you've got a 3.5 mm
headphone jack so you can monitor your
audio and playback and more importantly
you have an omnidirectional microphone
with noise suppression
we'll talk more about that later now on
top of that it comes with two
accessories which is the foam windsock
for general use and a furry mint sock
that helps to minimize wind noise so
yeah of course then you have your usb to
usbc uh charging cable but yeah that
it's as simple as it gets guys as simple
as it gets there you wanna see the cable
there you go
cable with that's it we're gonna check
out how it performs and the only way to
do this is to head outdoors so let's go
okay hi everyone we're here outdoors
on a busy street
and uh we're just using the iphone 13
pro with its inbuilt mic now i have to
speak a little loudly now because i'm
also speaking through a mask
and yeah hopefully there's a significant
difference once we pair up
the razer saren bt let's check it out
all right guys so i kind of ran into
some trouble uh with the razer seven bt
already uh it seems that the iphone 13
camera app the native camera app is not
able to differentiate what mic to use
so i had to download filmic pro and this
is where i can customize the audio from
there and just set it to bluetooth
microphone and bing bam boom we got the
microphone working now so you can see
i'm wearing headphones i've got it all
wired up i've got like one meter worth
of slack
running throughout my shirt and
connected to
the razer serum bt so i guess there's
one caveat that's a little annoying
the fact that you have to use wired
headphones or wired earbuds to connect
and basically get site tone to monitor
the razer seven bt
it's not as natural sounding
so maybe if you're an rl streamer that
prefers to have a little bit of
ambient noise you can adjust it this is
the razer serum bt with the noise
suppression completely turned off
how would it sound i would assume that
it's actually still better than the
built-in microphone in the iphone 13 pro
now with that being said right we should
compare it to one of our video
production microphones which is the rode
wireless go 2.
pretty much the same thing though it has
a transmitter and a receiver and i can
hook it directly to my iphone 13 pro so
let's just see how that performs and
compare the two
all right so we're recording right now
with the wireless go to microphone this
is the receiver i got a transmitter
clip to my shirt and this is what it
sounds like go-to microphone does not
have noise suppression so it is what it
is normally you attach it to a lavalier
microphone this is already a 250 300
microphone and you have to use two
devices the transmitter and the receiver
with the seven bt
it's more or less plug and play right
just one device and it has noise
suppression the road mic has maybe about
four or five hours so there you have it
guys that's uh the end of our
real world test so let's head back to
the studio and i'll share with you my
final thoughts so there you have it the
razer serum bt toldja is going to
perform very well but of course it
doesn't come without its setbacks one
being that you have to use the 3.5 mm
headphone jack to plug in your earbuds
or the headphones to playback audio this
includes when you have to call your
colleagues in a zoom meeting whatsoever
in your mobile
you can't play back
simultaneously with the microphone and
until your phone speakers you have to
use the 3.5 mm headphone jack now of
course this is not razer's fault it's
our technology limitations with
bluetooth right now
uh it just doesn't work with the current
devices but yeah who knows maybe when
the v2 comes out by then technology gets
so good that we can plug in true
wireless earbuds simultaneously with the
microphone and your mobile device i'm
pretty sure you have an understanding of
how well it performs would i recommend
this to streamers and vloggers
yes definitely yes six hours is more
than enough again with the quick charge
of just 1.5 hours from zero to 100
you you are basically gonna run
a sabbath on you can run a sabbath on or
follow thorn on twitch that is
completely possible so that's it for the
razer streaming lineup we've talked
about the razer seven bt the razer audio
mixer and the razer key light chroma
but i mean i'm really excited for what
else razer has installed i'm not saying
because i'm a fanboy
okay maybe just a little bit speaking as
a razer fanboy but
razer is heading to a good place with
the live streaming products man i mean
look talking about fan loyalists sure
but for anyone who is out there any
gamer any streamer who has heard of
razer
you know how
uh
premiumly priced razer can be
some of the products here are actually
worth the investment so yeah just take
note about that so with that's it what
do you think about the prices and which
of these products are you going to get
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below and while you're
at it do consider subscribing and liking
this video it goes a long way
till next time this is zacky i will see
you on the next one adios
[Music]
you